jean luc mélenchon pourquoi il est
contre cette loi inique c'est juste pour
lui une loi anti musulman et dire ça je
suis inquiet c'est important moi ça me
blesse parce qu'aucun musulman qui
pratique sa religion
tranquillement dans le respect des lois
de la république ne doit se sentir visés
par cette loi
quels articles et contre les musulmans
lequel la polygamie est ce qu on doit
l'accepter en france c'est inacceptable
certificat de virginité inacceptable etc
etc
rien ne va contre les musulmans mais
c'est bien pour monsieur mélenchon parce
qu il se repositionne et il permet de
parler à son électorat qui lui est
séparatiste
parce que monsieur mélenchon elle assume
d'être séparatistes c'est bien dommage
parce que profondément je pense que vous
étiez un laïc républicain joe hickman au
chorizo est dommage mais je recueille
des dons mais ses réponses et développer
votre point de vue je je l'écouterai
mais ne m'attribue et pas des positions
s'il ya quelqu'un qui n'est pas
séparatistes ici comme vous dites c'est
bien moi parce que je défends l'idée
d'une république une et indivisible et
dans la bataille que je mène aujourd'hui
je la mène contre ceux qui ont te cette
attitude électoraliste qui consiste à
penser que en montrant du doigt les
musulmans ils vont comme ça reprendre
les électeurs de l'extrême droite bon ça
c'est leur but moi je me bats pour
l'unité de la france et le respect qui
est dû aux personnes vous avez vous dire
que dans cette loi il ya 50 et un
article 400 paragraphe par une loi anti
musulman mais c'est ce qui est
intéressant mais cirilli annales qui est
intéressant de voir c'est ils écrivent
des tas de choses je veux dire quand
même un mot sur les thèmes qui ont été
évoqués mais il ne parle que des
musulmans tout le long du débat et vous
avez même eu une députée elle rmc donc
pas mon camp
qui dit ici c'est le procès de l'islam
du matin au soir alors vous avez entendu
comme moi tous donc c'est pas moi qui
invente elle vient de dire le la
polygamie est ce que nous allons être
pour la polygamie c'est déjà interdit en
france c'est déjà interdite alors si
vous voulez lutter contre toute forme de
polygamie j'aime mieux vous dire vous
allez
commence à rentrer dans we bail à la
polygamie officielle ne m'attendais pas
prendre la polygamie battu sur me dit
non alors oui c'est pas ça permet à dire
à vous comme à d'autres
laissez-moi terminé parce que je suis
pas aussi vif et que vous faut qu on
trouver des arguments il me faut le
temps des expositions de l'hiver
polygamie et déjà condamné oui les
mariages forcés sont déjà interdits les
certificat de virginité c'est déjà
interdit donc tout ça a été mis là
dedans pouvoir pendant des heures
suspecté une partie de la population en
songe d'avoir de l'affection pour ce
genre de thèse mais pourquoi c'était le
mot camille saint saëns aujourd'hui
interdit en chirurgie ou pas mais on me
dit la vérité
on donne aux produits non mais c'est
mais aux étrangers d'être en situation
de polygamie en france aujourd'hui
commerciales des contrats a demandé
quand vous demander des papiers et que
vous êtes en situation de polygamie
ce n'est pas quelque chose de blocs en
vous pouvez être étranger jamais de la
vie vous raconter des histoires
attendait chante on vous rappelez des
papiers nulle part on vous dit être
polygame wilfrid pas madame vous seriez
mirabeau est la bienvenue républicain ou
bien vous anime acronis marié à et n'ont
qu'à dénoncer les traités qu'ils ont
signés avec les pays dans lesquels la
france reconnaît qu'il ya des statuts
officiels de polygamie et par conséquent
lorsqu'il y a des retraites à payer lui
paye aux femmes
dd polygame mais ça c'est des traités à
ses petits souliers
je dois je ne défends pas ça je suis
content j'aurais si vous parlez de
séparatisme alors je vais vous poser une
question
le vrai séparatisme religieux c'est
celui qui fait qu'en alsace moselle
on paye les curés les rabats 60 millions
par an et que nous payons tout ce qu'ils
veulent je ne veux pas payer de curé ni
de rabat son fils qu'il est je vais
continuer en vidéo
présent à la team c'est celui des riches
lorsqu'ils créent leur quartier
lorsqu'ils sont entre eux lorsqu'ils ne
laisse pas les gens vous prenez des
villes où vous avez 2 % de logements
sociaux contre la loi la loi dit une
chose et fait le contraire ça ça vous
dérange pas et on s'est montrés du doigt
c'est malheureux jules membres en les
soupçonnant des prêts à faire des
mariages forcés et polygames et des
certificats d'origine it et satirique et
oui vous et mélenchon cgt banalement
réactionnaire et vous n'aimez pas
quelques et vous n'aimez pas l'unité de
la france voilà votre cible qui
n'aimaient pas les femmes
laurent soulier ne vous dérange pas que
les femmes soient voilées que des femmes
pour des burkinis en hachant lieu ce
sujet ça ne vous dérange pas qu'on a
changé sujet horaires décalés vous en
sciences et là par les ans les perdre et
comme vous êtes méchante et agressions y
regarder de vilain visage crispé contre
moi moi je suis pour l'égalité halde oui
oui pas moi peut-être est-ce que vous
êtes juste et pas nous dire que déjà au
repos les salons les enlever non m les
lauréats blood et vous vous rendez
compte du mécanisme regardez comment ils
procèdent tifenn g vient de dire vous
n'êtes pas pour l'égalité des amériques
de quoi vous parlez ma pauvre qui a été
celui c'est pas mal j'ai voté avec
d'autres un pas que moi mais je suis
nous avons été nombreux à voter la
bannière là pour toutes les lois qui
établissent et l'égalite jem sur la
mélodie est ce que c'est que cette
accusation gratuite sur le voyez c'est
comme ça qu'ils font ça fait des jours
que ça dure fickett dessus prétexte de
défendre l'égalité
vous avez des gens ils font exactement
le profil de son laurent seigne expose
son expo sud vérifiez vous envoler de
travail et que je n'invente mélenchon
invente pas moi parce que monsieur
mélenchon dit qu'il n'y a pas de
certificat de virginité ce n'est pas la
vérité même des médecins remercie la loi
parce qu'ils sont sous pression
obligé d'en faire des certificat de
virginité il n'y a qu'en pensée de
l'ordre qu'il est condamné c'est déjà
interdit par l'ordre des médecins je ne
sais pas de quoi vous parlez papa par la
loi et ça ne suffit pas pour protéger
ensuite sur la polygamie vous savez que
étrangers on leur donne des certitudes
et la possibilité d'y monter en l'ayant
polygame cémenté tout le mans alors
non non non vous mentez et tous vous dit
vous savez bien non je ne sais pas bien
moi je sais le contraire